quand ce manchot royal a monté la rampe
pour embarquer dans un avion cargo
direction calgary ils sont est peut-être
que c'était un vol sans retour
lui et ses congénères était trop vieux
pour supporter deux voyages en savait
que on allait ramener des jeunes
fringant si on veut comme ce serait
comme un transport pour les ceux qui
partent et divya donc un transport pour
ceux qui arrivaient de cagliari le
traumatisme du déménagement a été fatale
pour environ 80 spécimens sur les 4500
qui ont dû être relocalisés pendant les
rénovations
c'est un exploit d'avoir réussi à
dépasser ces animaux-là et de les
ramener à bon port avec une mortalité au
teint de maladie d'accident qui aurait
pu survenir au but au cours du transport
donc ça c'est que ça channel
oui on savait qu'on avait une population
qui était quand même assez pour certains
est-ce que les toutes les morts on les
avait escompté
non bien entendu on a eu des petites
tragédies la plus inattendue de ces
tragédies
c'est les mouettes qui en ont été
victimes une belette a réussi à
s'introduire dans leur enclos à
saint-eustache
elle ya fait une quinzaine de morts ce
sont les chauves-souris qui ont payé le
plus lourd tribut leurs vêtements
choisis à écorcher mortellement les
ailes fragile d'une quarantaine d'entre
elles mais est-ce que leur vie a été
beaucoup raccourcis
je serais surpris une chance sourit ça
peut vivre trente ans c'est une espèce
qui est un peu mal aimé
ah mais moi je t'aime et le reste des
décès a très probablement été causé par
le chamboulement dans la vie des animaux
clermain de stress le fait que les
animaux peuvent arrêter de manger
certaines maladies peuvent avoir des
conséquences graves sur leur espérance
de gain les équipes du biodôme vont
investiguer chacun pour que d'autres
puissent apprendre de cette expérience
en attendant que le public puisse venir
retrouver bientôt les animaux voyageurs
ici mathieu prost radio canada montréal